Nancy Rios: So, we'll go ahead and jump here. So, your niche starts with you. We will be doing, a quick,
Nancy Rios: just connecting with each other now. And we'll be doing a get-to-know-you activity. This is gonna be, like, a very easy, conversation, and, you guys will all have, rules on what you will be doing. So…
Nancy Rios: Essentially, what you will be doing, we will put you guys into groups of three. One will read the question that we have in a doc here.
Nancy Rios: Let's see, I think I received it like this.
Sathya Narayanan: I think the…
Nancy Rios: Yeah.
Sathya Narayanan: the here button, is linked to the template, I think.
Nancy Rios: Okay.
Nancy Rios: Oh, there we go.
Nancy Rios: Okay. So, yeah, we'll put you guys into groups of three. So, one of you will read the question, one of you will share your answer, and then one of them will… one of you will write down the answer and take some notes.
Nancy Rios: We do ask that one person from the group, submit your work on Canvas, so just one person in the group is able… you're able to do that. Like I mentioned, each of you have a role. The roles are here.
Nancy Rios: like I said, a reader, an answer, and then a note-taker. These are the questions. These questions should be just
Nancy Rios: very flowy, having an easy conversation with each other.
Nancy Rios: Any questions before we, put you guys into groups?
Nancy Rios: You are going to be making a copy of the doc.
Nancy Rios: Sorry, Saadia?
Sathya Narayanan: I was going to say, I don't think the intention is for you to answer all the questions, right? Like, kind of pick a few and ask.
Sathya Narayanan: There's a conversation starters, we don't want it to become, like, a…
Sathya Narayanan: interview where you're asking questions. Like, we just wanted to give you some conversation starter to get you into a conversation, and then, like, kind of… and we also wanted to know what you talked about, so we kind of assigned somebody as a note-taker, so that we can… we can also know, right? We couldn't be in all the breakout rooms, so that's why we have that, right? Ideally, we'll just have you both, two of you, talk to each other.
Sathya Narayanan: But then we won't know anything in terms of what happened in the record, right? So this is not like a test or a… we're not going to grade the book… notebook, sorry, the document or anything. It is more of a way for us to have you talk to each other, and each of you listen, but then we also take… get some notes so that we can read it and kind of get a sense of
Sathya Narayanan: The community that we are working with.
Sathya Narayanan: So I need to create breakout rooms, and I'm trying to do that. I should have done that faster. So,
Sathya Narayanan: If I have, two to three participants, so maybe the one team is… one is going to have two people.
Sathya Narayanan: And one of us should go join them and be the note-taker. So I can go to room 7 and be the note-taker. Other rooms all have 3 people, and I think Nicholas posted the…
Sathya Narayanan: instructions, so you can also see the instruction here, right? One of you make a copy. I think all of you may have to submit on Canvas, but one person make a copy, share it with your groupmate by getting their email addresses, and then,
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah. Have a conversation and take notes. That's it, basically, right? We're given some structure, but, like.
Sathya Narayanan: Talk about whatever you want to tackle. I think it's perfectly fine, right?
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah.
Nancy Rios: good, Catch here. Yeah, you don't have to answer all these questions.
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah. That'll be a long time, yeah.
Nancy Rios: We'll be here forever. Okay.
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah. And we are doing, what, like, about 12 to 15 minutes? So, think about it as 4 to 5 minutes per person, then you rotate, right? So the next person asks a question, next person answers, and next person takes stake notes, so you have 3 rounds there. So spend about, like, yeah, 4 minutes, yeah, 3 to 4 minutes or 5 minutes or so, yeah.